so I believe this is your first animated
feature yes so what was the process like
was there anything about it that really
surprised you um no I got introduced to
smaller roles like on television
animation but it's just a different way
of working and it's interesting like all
the intricate pieces that go together
and all of the people that you know have
to come together to make one character
it just blows my mind so it's just a
different way of working you know I love
it because I was always an only child
until my father remarried he had my
sister 17 years later so I was very
creative I had to be very creative so
this kind of work is great for me
because there you don't have any stimuli
you don't have any one opposite of you
there's no set there's no props it's
just you and your imagination and maybe
a storyboard or the picture of your
character so I mean I like it there's no
hair there's no makeup involved works
for me but that always is like even the
princess scene when she changes
everybody into comfy clothes you know
like that's the princess scene I want to
be exactly yeah
so it's it's great I love it I love the
process speaking of all the people and
also all the time that goes into making
a movie like this I often think we all
know you know the famous face is the
headliners that are working on these
movies but there are so many other
people that nobody's aware of so
faceless if you had to name an unsung
hero of this movie who would it be
I don't even think I've met them I just
know feel enriched that's who I see all
the time its studio so I mean it's so
many it's not even like a set were you
running to the grips or the electricians
these are people I never see their face
lists like they're in the office
somewhere that I've never been to and
I'm sorry I haven't met you but you all
matter it's so true yeah I don't think
people get it like it's not like I'm
going to the studio just where the
people work and I'm like hey guys I'm
going to turn voice my like I literally
was doing my studio work in Chicago
filling rich with flowers to Chicago Wow
where sometimes they would be or I would
come to LA but it would be at
studio out in Burbank not at Disney yeah
I feel like I never really fully
understood how many people got involved
and how important they all were until I
visited Pixar once and we toured each
department and it's just you reel at the
head of the department and you don't
think about things like cinematography
and blocking and lighting and it's also
key here and how long it takes like what
we do in the booth that's just like but
like it's a year it took us a year to
put this in the can I mean cuz they're
constantly tweaking the lighting and
tweaking I mean so much it's so much
it's so much that we couldn't even
imagine one of my favorite scenes in
this movie is one of your scenes and
it's the comments you know we're so
happy that you guys address that and I
kind of want to spread the positivity of
dealing with negative comments on the
internet so has anyone ever given you
really good advice for managing that
yourself yeah just don't take it
personal you know people hurt people
hurt people
you know and misery loves company all
the things that my mother taught me but
yet again there are those days where I
just don't want to hear it it hurts my
feelings so I'm gonna clap back you know
but most times I ignore it because I
understand what's happening this person
woke up on the wrong side of the bed you
know it's almost sometimes I just want
to go who hurt you it's gonna be okay
yeah God loves you reaction if you let's
say in real life were the real buzz tube
algorithm what would the feed be
populated with what would you be giving
all the love to I'm probably
inspirational videos or animals or
babies or funny stuff things that make
people forget about how screwed up
things are right now pretty sure I'd be
all movie trailers and cat videos that's
it yes it would be a much happier
happier days yes
[Music]